- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is do what you love.
Over to you, Ivanka Trump.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I look around at my
girlfriends and at my guy friends
and they're in jobs that
they don't really have
a lot of growth potential
and that they're not
passionate about, and I think
if we're ever going to make
bold decisions, it has to be
at this point in our life.
You know, we have to be out there,
we have to be experimenting,
we have to be looking
for that which makes us tick,
and I think a big part
of that evolution for me
was really, summer jobs and working
and making sure to actually,
you know, get into the world,
and try different things
and eliminate those
which is as useful,
eliminating those career paths
that you're not interested
in, as it is, you know,
doing things that do interest you.
But I think just being
bold and taking risks
when you're young is so
important because I can't imagine
working the hours that I do
if I didn't fundamentally love it.
And I think that's the
difference between somebody's
successful and somebody
that's extremely successful.
Somebody that's good and somebody
that's exceptionally good
is the level of drive,
which directly stems from passion.
- So this message has to be
the most repeated message
that I hear over and over
and over and over again
from people who have had success.
And success in general,
not just as entrepreneurs.
I started off this channel
only focusing on entrepreneurs
and we branched out and
we've looked at athletes,
and we've looked at musicians,
we've looked at singers,
we've looked at artists,
we've looked at inventors.
And consistently, across everybody
who's reached the top of their game,
the thing that they always say, always
is you have to do what you love.
- To do something that I love doing.
- I love building teams.
- Love the process of
solving the problems.
- That's how much love I have
for this thing that I do.
- I love every minute of it.
- Really love to do it.
- Get involved in things that you love.
- You're so passionate,
excited, and in love with.
- And you may have heard
that message before
and you may say that that's boring
and it's not interesting and
I already know that, Evan,
but are you doing it?
'Cause the next part comes into
how do I find what I'm passionate about?
How do I find the thing that I love?
And this is where so
many people fall down.
You find what you love
by exploring, by testing,
by trying, by when you
get an idea for something,
you don't sit on it for five years
and hope one day it's going to happen.
You find some small way
to get started, anything.
An idea pops into your head,
find a small way to get started
and see if it makes you come alive or not.
If you want to open a snowboarding school,
maybe you should learn how
to snowboard first, right?
And you can go and learn how
to snowboard right now, go.
Pick up a snowboard, rent
it, go take a lesson and see.
Does it make you come alive?
Do you want to keep
doing this thing or not?
Instead of making this
list of all these things
that one day you're going
to get to and never do.
'Cause what ends up
happening is you settle.
You settle.
You have ideas for what to do.
You never actually go
out and do a lot of them.
And what you're in, is
okay, it's pretty good.
The enemy of greatness is not crap.
It's not terrible.
The enemy of greatness is good.
Your situation right now,
yeah, it could be better
but could be a lot worse too, you're good.
You're good, so you don't
have the hustle and drive
to go for great.
That's where a lot of people fall down.
I'd like to say that the
greatest basketball player
of all time is not Michael Jordan,
it's not Wilt Chamberlain,
it's somebody who we've never heard.
The greatest basketball of all time
is a manager at Starbucks
because he never picked up a
basketball 'cause he never knew
that he had that talent,
that passion, that ability
'cause he didn't try,
'cause he settled too soon.
He settled too early for okay
and lives an okay life,
instead of having Michael
Jordan level talent
and dominating an industry.
You have the ability to
dominate an industry.
You have Michael Jordan
level talent at something
that you will wake up
every day and want to crush
and go out and practice
and take shot after shot
after shot and watch tape
and be obsessed with.
You have that for something
and if it's not for what
you're doing right now,
then stop settling.
Stop mailing it in.
Stop being okay with an okay life.
You could do more and
not just for yourself.
You could do more to
contribute to your family,
to contribute to your community,
to contribute to your country,
to help the world with something.
You have that ability,
that talent inside you,
and what are you doing with it?
If you are not that obsessed
about what you're doing right now,
I'm not saying drop it
immediately and just
float and hope something comes.
But you've had ideas, right?
You've had ideas of things to do.
Stop sitting on them.
Try it out.
I never thought I would own
the largest salsa dance studio
maybe in the world.
I never thought it.
I never thought about salsa dancing at all
but I went to a salsa club
and I liked it and I wanted to learn more,
and I wanted to do it
again, and do it again,
and practice and get better and improve.
One thing led to another and here we are.
That's the story of a
lot of entrepreneurs.
If you have an idea for
something, you owe it to yourself
to give it a shot, to try it,
to take some small step
and move it forward.
And you may try it and hate it,
and that's great information.
Or you may try it and love
it and want to come back
and do it again, and do
it again, and do it again.
And if you find that thing
that you want to just
keep doing and keep grinding
and keep getting better at
and keep improving, and
keep helping others with,
that's the thing that you could have
Michael Jordan level talent at
and you owe it to yourself to go for it.
So the question today, two parts.
One, first part.
If you know what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at,
I want you to leave it
in the comments below.
Part two, if you don't know what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at,
I want you to write down three things
that you're going to start
to explore this week.
That you've had ideas on
and you haven't done yet
and you're going to try it out this week.
Three ideas, leave it
in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Scott Stokes
from swainwoodham.co.nz.
Thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book, Scott,
Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey Believe Nation, we're
also looking at doing
a top ten rules for success for Ivanka.
Here is a sneak peek at some of the clips
that we're looking at.
I hope you enjoy the bonus.
- I think the only way to build confidence
is through trial and error.
I think when you're young,
one of the challenges
is that you're insecure
about knowing nothing
and you think people expect
you to have all the answers.
Now, as a 34-year-old,
I'm okay with not having all the answers.
I recognize there's a lot I don't know
and I own that and I love that
and it makes me curious and
helps me continue to grow.
That's why I always tell
people, just get out
and do things.
You have to learn through trial and error,
you have to just try.
And every time you try something,
you get a little bit more experience,
a little bit more wisdom,
you build a little bit more confidence.
So to all of you young
people, just get out there,
start doing things, take risks,
just, just try.
- I ask all the women that I interview,
can women truly have it all?
Because when someone looks at your life
from the outside in,
you're a mother, you're a wife,
you're a real estate developer,
you have a full time job,
but you have another full time job
because you also have a very
successful clothing and
accessories business.
So it seems like you have it all,
but do you think women
really can have it all?
- I think it's a very difficult question
and it's one that I try not
to answer for other people
because I think by its nature,
what is having it all mean?
It means different things
to different people.
You know for me, it's very
important to have a family
but it's also very important
to be professionally fulfilled.
For some people, one of those is important
and the other isn't, so you know,
I think you have to figure
out what your priorities are,
in life are, and then architect your life
around those priorities.
I think when people start to get lost,
it's when their lives
are grossly inconsistent
with their value set
and their core priorities.
So for me, you know at
the end of every week,
I sort of do a self assessment of
did I spend my time in the right way?
Was I where I needed to be?
You know, it's, there
are some days it's okay
to not be home for dinner.
If I have a big deal,
my priority may be that
for that moment of time
but I also know, if my
child ever gets sick,
if anything happens, well there
goes every other priority.
So I think it's always a
balance, and you just have to do
the best you can do.